[Music]
it's not funny but finding a man that is
on Tiffany Haddish is mine and she is
telling all to her girls trip co-star
Jada pinkett-smith are you dating
I like to date I really don't have a lot
of time for it but when somebody asked
me out on a date that I'm interested in
like hanging out with I will clear this
I will make some time one man she made
time for Drake he asked her to be in a
music video and she thought his offer to
hang out together
was a date he was like let me take you
to dinner I'll go get my mustache get my
armpits laughs got me a nice little trip
but on Mondays episode of Jada series
read Table Talk on Facebook watch
Tiffany explains that her date with
Drake never happy okay so what time will
we get it out are you sitting the card
like where we going and he's like oh man
my bad family emergency I'm in Canada
right now and I was like I was with
these two when they shot there sit down
and you can't miss that they are close
you really have fallen in love with her
having your voice playing like Tiffany
Gina now this is what's happening I go
okay well Tiffany this year okay notice
Tiffany had a rough childhood part of it
spent in the foster care system she
recently had an amazing moment with her
mother who's just gotten out of a mental
institution she's at my house this is
the first time she said like she's proud
how did it make you feel though when
your mother told you that she was proud
oh I was it took everything in my heart
not to just break down the car I just
hugged her so tight I went to the
bathroom turned on the shower jumped
[Music]